four police officers have been killed in
a knife attack inside the Paris police
headquarters near Noctor Dam reports the
attacker also worked there insulin
Rashid is with me now what do we know
about what happened okay this really is
a moving situation happening in the
center of Paris as we speak this was at
Paris Police Headquarters a building
where you would expect is extremely
secure and that's why the news that's
coming out that this potential
perpetrator was someone that actually
worked inside Paris Police Headquarters
what we are being told is that four
police officers have died and then
police officers shot this perpetrator so
in total five deaths in Paris this
afternoon just some quotes coming to
bfmtv one of the local TV sources
they're saying the alleged perpetrator
started in his office before continuing
on to the premises of the prefecture the
asylum was an administrative colleague
who had more than 20 years in office now
it's not immediately clear how far the
asylum got inside we are aware that
there are potentially some injuries as
well k and the motors of the attack is
something that we're just not aware of
at the minutes the information is very
sparse and there's also other sources
saying that now the Paris prime minister
the French Prime Minister Edward
Philippe is at the scene along with the
interior for ministry and also Emmanuel
macron making his way down to central
Paris as well I think we can see some
pictures now of obviously emergency
services attending to the scene there
will be a lot of rush in central Paris
now after this attack we know that Paris
has been a frequent sue some attacks in
recent years as we don't know the motive
for this attack but what we are hearing
is that this was someone who worked
inside Paris Police Headquarters they
were armed with a knife they attacked
officers inside the police headquarters
killing at least
four police officers before he was then
fatally shot and their words from a
French police union to a local TV this
building is actually located near not
true damn so not too damn Cathedral so
just across the street from there so
that just shows you how central really
we are talking here it's believed that
four police officers faced those those
fatal wounds and then the officer shot
the attacker in a situation that appears
to be self-defense there the words
coming from police union in Paris but as
I said Kaye this really is a developing
story that took place a midday in Paris
and we'll keep you up-to-date with with
the latest events okay for now thank you